well in in in some ways it's altered in
some ways it's changed in other ways
it's remained the same I think a
programs change in x change but two
values that really don't change I mean
people's our concern for other people or
people's understanding of what the
Constitution is a really about or and
the Bill of Rights and their devotion to
it maybe it changes it that we see a
time when those rights maybe maybe
threatened more than they have been at
at other times but in the concern that I
see on the floor of the United States
Senate among Democrats among Republicans
there's a very still cork understanding
and awareness that America is just not a
land but it's a promise and that each
time and each generation has to fulfill
the the challenges of the time and the
promise of America I think when I first
arrived in the United States Senate it
was primarily in knocking down walls of
discrimination we still have a ways to
go but we were looking then after
passing Medicare Medicaid higher
education at that time now there are
different challenges both in terms of
trying to protect constitutional rights
still in terms of education and health
care and also in terms of how we can end
a war so the issues themselves might
change the institution itself has
altered and changed probably the most
dramatic change has been a sort of the
power of money in in politics I'm
long-standing a supporter of public
financing I think people ought to be
accountable to their constituents and
not accountable to the the contributors
but that's still a battle that has to be
a work through in the in the Congress
but I think this what what is left now
in terms of when I first arrived and now
still is much more important than what
divides us what what remains the same
you